it's monday mcguire day i was able to
say it
spider-man 3 toby mcguire plot details
revealed topher grace is going to show
up as
venom there's a sandman they're going to
have too many villains crammed into one
harry osborne's going to die at the end
sacrificing himself
he has a whole character arc there i
gave all the plot details away ah
spoilers
the comedy is constantly gold around
here
never stops mining the gold we're
watching cosmic wonders video let's do
it
how's it going everybody it's morning
welcome back to the channel on my
channel things marvel and
everything dude if you're gonna take
over for warren someday you're gonna
have to know this
but it's saturday night and we got some
pretty big news now the past few days
have been
absolutely insane for marvel and star
wars fans
at disney's investor day they revealed a
ton of new
marvel projects but they didn't talk
squat about spider-man
recently has been about these new
projects but let's not forget about one
of the most exciting things happening
right now and that is spider-man 3.
and today thanks to an exclusive report
from fandomwire.com
we have some new details about the film
and about doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
both involving toby mcguire before we
dive into it be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
tony stark quantum suit funko pop i'm
picking a winner next friday
so as expected it appears that toby
mcguire's role in spider-man 3 is not
just going to be for a quick
role his time in the mcu isn't just
going to be in spider-man 3 but he is in
fact going to go on to be in doctor
strange in the multiverse
spider-man toby mcguire spider-man that
is isn't just going to pop up in
spider-man 3 and maybe make a quick dude
but he'll actually have an important
role in what's happening nick fury of
facebook
i said did they were able to get it back
as hammering he's directing
yeah i'll connect to spider-man 3 and
spider-man 3 oh
that has and we can already see how
wanda is going to be in doctor strange
too and doctor strange is going to be in
spider-man 3.
and this new report from fandomwire
gives us a little bit more information
in their report they say they can
exclusively reveal that toby maguire
spider-man will have a role to play in
dodger strange in the multiverse of
madness toby mcguire will of course have
a role in the third spider-man film
but his role doesn't stop there and they
issue a spoiler warning so i will issue
the same if you don't want to know
anything about it
click away now they're going to say both
monovision and the third spider-man
movie are going to deal with the reality
warping and multiverse shenanigans
and of course this is already confirmed
but they say due to the fabric of
reality being disrupted in one division
it's gonna be in need of some fixing
the mcu's third spider-man flick will
deal with the fallout
however the problem won't be solved
until doctor strange two and
it'll be up to steven strange to help
out wanda but
he won't be alone according to fandom
wire toby mcguire is going to be helping
and perhaps he can't get back to his own
reality until our main mcu timeline and
universe has been proud oh that is
really insane are going to somehow be
colliding
it doesn't actually seem like doctor
strange is going to open portals to
these other universes but the problem
may actually be
universes colliding into each other for
some reason whatever that oh i love this
for so many reasons
we don't know yet but we do know that
it's going to be up to doctor strange to
fix it
and now apparently toby mcguire is going
to be sticking around after spider-man 3
and is going to be helping doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
super exciting news so let me know how
excited you are about this
in the comments down below don't forget
i have so many loving thoughts about
this
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me and i'm going to share none of that
i'm just going to talk about one nitpick
thanks warren for reporting on that
buddy
you know lately a lot of the [ __ ] that's
been reported on from your channel
in the last year has come to fruition
and pretty accurate so
trusting brownie points for the guy has
only elevated
let's talk about some of this so yeah we
made jokes in the past about how
maybe they were able to core toby
mcguire into coming in by getting sam
raimi for doctor strange and considering
that doctor strange is going to be in
spider-man 3. maybe there was some type
of talk and some
leeway help from sam raimi on his end
that was just one
theory floating around and one thing
i've always wanted
is for toby maguire's spider-man
specifically his
face that i think most of us care way
more about that properly including the
ninja garfield
and the reason i wanted his to conclude
because spider-man 1 and 2 were freaking
incredible and spider-man 3 not so great
the
2004
first i forget the year it doesn't
matter so yeah that version was not that
great i've wanted him to have a proper
conclusion
and we didn't get that spider-man 4. and
i thought okay so maybe with this new
spider-man 3 movie with toby mcguire
coming in
he might be able to get that conclusion
that we've all been wanted even if it's
just like 10 minutes of screen time they
managed to put some
good final chapter on it that would be
great but there was always this part
in me that was going i wish sam raimi
was directing it though
yeah always this part of me that was
going i wish it was sam raimi to
have been behind the camera to capture
tobey maguire the fact that
sam raimi they've already they're
already filming i think i forget what
they said on disney investor day but i
think they're already filming um
multiverse of madness sam raimi
directing that and if tom mcguire gets
to be in it that even makes the whole
contract negotiation sound that much
bigger the whole thing with how it was
hard getting toby to sign on because he
wanted a lot of money but i'm like well
if you want him to appear in two movies
versus one it's gonna be a big deal
it's gonna be a big contract yeah
that'll be two movies with the option of
more depending on how successful this is
i'm sure
so yeah i'm sure there's a lot of like
protracted
long-term stuff to suss out i mean this
sounds like an awesome idea because it
also
marks to me maybe this kind of turning
point where now that marvel has yet done
their big slam dunk of just
setting up the universe now it's like on
their massive scale
they can start experimenting in ways
that are probably
assured to at least attract people's
attention and yeah i like this idea of
introducing him in spider-man 3. you
know it still has to have an
individual story that wraps up but the
concept of
you know the stakes of spider-man 3 will
then carry over into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness all brought on by one division
that's
through line it's a crazy new throughput
it's like a serial movies in a whole
other way yeah you know yeah i mean to
deal with the i i
for some reason my i was hearing like oh
it's gonna like lead into this and lead
into that but i'm like oh
crap for some reason my mind didn't
really register
the amount of damage of mind bending
warp bending reality
scenarios of how much that's going to
mess up everything within the mcu yeah
and how that's going to lead over from a
series to really explore and kind of
understand it lead into spider-man and
lead into doctor strange i think is a
a really cool new through line to follow
it's experimental and
i think it's cool that you'll get like
doctor strange and spider-man 3 and then
you'll get a different spider-man and dr
strange so it doesn't feel repetitive
and you could really get some strong ear
marks the differences if this is true
it sounds likely and it's something i
would really want and for story purposes
and also with the
nostalgia factor of tobin mcguire and
sam raimi getting an opportunity to
truly reunite
major reason why and it would also make
more sense yeah i think when i'm
thinking about the contract
like what was making them such a
difficult time signing on i mean even if
it was just spider-man 3
it makes sense if you want them for two
movies especially one where he sounds
more like a pivotal role
yeah one that sounds like a lot more
focused significant and a marker of the
stakes at hand if they're going to have
like multi
like universes colliding with each other
yeah whatever they list the earth
of toby maguire spiderman is from like
if they call it like
earth o2 or something yeah you know if
the ending credits say
spiderman earth 02 rule return and dr
strange i'm like oh man
he's such a cool text to read and now
we're going to have to catalogue all our
spider-man by earth
oh yeah it's going to do that we have to
yeah all right guys well what do you
think about the news of spider-man
toby mcgregor crossing over specifically
into doctor strange multiverse
madness leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to cosmic wonder subscribe to
us if you want click that notification
bell hit that like button last but not
least
deontay w tongue punch fart box john
wanted to shout you
out that's right man i just want you
know when i hear your name
tongue punch fart box every time each
part of it each part of the word shows
up in those splashy
onomatopia comic book panels you're a
colorful personality
i always love seeing you in our live
streams you always got interesting
takes interesting movie pics and uh
you're an agile cat man
you could be kicking ass out there with
spider-man so uh this video kind of made
me think of you
in that way and i'm really happy to
include you in our multiverse of the
reject nation because in a whole other
life you found a different channel
and you don't even care about us this
shout out is going off road a little bit
but the
important part is it's the holidays and
i hope that you're doing well
i just wish you all the love and warmth
of the season
i don't know i hope you do it well man
be well you know you could have said
what you could have just said it's
christmas time so i hope this christmas
you give everyone a box a christmas
present box and then you open it
and it's a tongue that farts and then it
punches you
boom instead of whatever this
ramble was sorry tongue punch fartbox
you deserve
quality